hey lauren hey billy how are you good
morning morgan hello morgan hi i love
that you're both together in the same
room that's awesome i'm loving that too
yeah it's nice right yeah so first of
all i love the movie when it came out in
2010 you know it has this massive cult
following now but the show is really
good as always i could not stop laughing
but i want to know from both of you what
was your reaction when you first saw the
movie
i laughed out loud i i had no
experience with magruber
i was one of those people who kind of
stopped watching saturday night live
yeah when i when i had children and
things um but uh they sent me the movie
it it had me in stitches almost from the
very beginning so
it's it's it was the new bar for comedy
it was you know i and so i i think
modern and bold
you know a bit of a hard r
just just you know shocking
super sincere
incredibly talented actors playing it as
if it was
you know ibsen and
and you know with fart jokes and
explosions right you know it's just
absurd
wonderful it's just yeah really
wonderful the highest art form
yeah absolutely well and both of your
characters are so serious which adds to
the comedy out of everyone out of the
cast or even just youtube who's the
first to break character when working
opposite will forte and the ridiculous
things that he has to say
you'll have to ask will no me
it was very hard it was impossible
it was it's such a pleasure and you know
before i i think there's a movie that
exists before action and after
that
like literally i love that movie oh my
god you got to see that movie i want to
see this movie
that's awesome lawrence how did you
handle all your scenes
uh you know it's really funny that you
should ask me that our director one of
our directors yorma
he asked me one time he said hey uh
lawrence do you do you ever get nervous
and my response was about what
[Laughter]
so
no i don't i mean you know i just i just
show up and try and hit the mark and
yeah stay in the stay in the thing it's
so silly what we're doing
like but in order for it to work
somebody has to kind of hold the line
absolutely so i'm really good at just
holding the line and not breaking unless
billy's around and then it's then it's
forget it yeah we
he makes me laugh we melt each other
sorry oh really i love that so much um i
was just talking to joseph lee anderson
uh and he said he was pretty nervous
working with you do you get that
reaction from people lawrence you know
you obviously are so good playing these
authorita authoritative roles i try not
to pay too much attention to it because
it really makes me nervous
the gravitas has entered the room
[Laughter]
maestro
[Laughter]
okay billy you have such a great role
because you get to play a villain what
can you tell us about this character and
the relationship with magruber because
there's history there
there is history we go back uh to an
ill-fated mission and
consistent with his you know wobbly
moral compass he made some decisions and
left his team uh
you know for dead and uh that didn't go
over too well with us uh
and and uh we return to uh seek
vengeance upon him and the world as we
know it um
it's uh it's on par with uh
you know a a rel a relative challenge
to
uh our the hero for our time right now
exactly uh so i think i think we come
with with enough uh firepower and mayhem
in store
uh worthy of mcgroover mcgruber
solutions mm-hmm and a you know throat
rib or a
yeah a throat rib rocks punch or
whatever i could listen to you two
describe magruber and your characters
like all day you guys are so funny
unfortunately we don't have that much
time yeah
i know i know i'm going to go better
she can stay yeah she can stick around
morgan hey yay billy thank you come on
morgan thank you you've got my back uh
lauren's great what's great about the
the general is he's now with with
mcgruber's ex-wife vic yes there's some
drama there now general
barrett for sushi uh is married to vicky
and uh is treating her very well he is
he's the king he's he's the he's the
king he's the man
and he takes care of his wife very well
and uh can we hold for as well as uber
as well as oh she threatens or reminds
perhaps not
takes care of her heart yes
there you go
so speaking of treating vicky so well uh
what was it like working with kristen
wiig this is one of the real you know
joys of being in part of this project
is working with kristen wiig obviously
working with will
and i had worked with uh ryan phillippe
maybe a decade prior to this so i mean
but you know both wig and forte are
absolute geniuses of what they do yeah
um nobody you know nobody does it better
so i was
just like oh i get to play with people
that play at this level yeah let's go
and and props to ryan in the mix on that
i'd add him to that genius list because
what he has to maintain
is the line he has to maintain i mean
it's hard enough for us to keep a
straight face right that i mean
his comic timing is brilliant and
it's his responses are so dry and he is
you know he kind of
he's i think the shepherd for the
audience he is he is the audience member
along for the ride right and it's such a
privileged uh position and delicate line
yeah to toe
um
but yeah
i mean working with kristen and will
magic
magic well perfect way to wrap up the
interview guys so nice getting to talk
to you congrats on the series like i
love the movie but the show is really
good
good
glad you liked it
it's a
great pleasure morgan thank you
you